[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein riesiger kontinent voller reichtümer
und eine schnellwahl bevölkerung er ist
der letzte kontinent dance zeitalter der
moderne eintritt ein weites land
unendliche möglichkeiten eine region auf
welche die volksrepublik china ihr
augenmerk gerichtet hat und dass sie ihr
kapital investiert hat chinesisches geld
und chinesische unternehmen entdecken
nun den ganzen kontinent ab eine
entwicklung die im westen starke
bedenken hervor ruft in den letzten
jahrzehnten begann sich die
wirtschaftliche und soziale landschaft
in afrika stark zu verändern folge
jahrzehntelanger fast zweifel umgingen
mal zu einem fast überbordenden
optimismus über einem heftigen und
unbändigen optimismus von 2000 bis 2018
will die extreme armut und mehr als 30
prozent reduziert die durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung stieg um mehr als zehn
jahre und die kindersterblichkeit wurde
halbiert darüber hinaus entwickelten
sich einige volkswirtschaften so schnell
dass man für sie eine eigene bezeichnung
einführte die afrikanischen plötzlich
nahm der letzte kontinent der vergessene
kontinent fahrt auf wie könnten wir uns
also nicht von der euphorie anstecken
lassen als afrika eigentlich bereit war
den wettlauf mit der moderne zu beginn
inmitten all dieser euphorie begann
investitionsprojekte auf dem ganzen
kontinent wie pilze aus dem boden zu
schießen und diese enormen investitionen
musste natürlich auch irgendwie
finanziert werden aber als afrika
anfängt zu wachsen war das kein problem
mehr ganz im gegenteil da die zinssätze
in den industrieländern auf einem
tiefstand waren wir ganz viele agenturen
und institutionen auf der ganzen welt
immer mehr kapital nach afrika zu leiten
wodurch sich die auslandsverschuldung
des kontinents in nur wenigen jahren
verdoppelte
das war jedoch kein problem sie gold man
es sich einfach leisten denn die
volkswirtschaften wuchsen so stark dass
die auslandsschulden keine echte
belastung darstellten relativ gesehen
hat sich die situation für viele länder
sogar verbessert aber natürlich wurde
dieses szenario durch den globalen
wirtschaftseinbruch in folge der korona
lockt das praktisch über nacht auf den
kopf gestellt
[Musik]
plötzlich sah sich afrika mit der ersten
rezession seit beginn des neuen
jahrhunderts konfrontiert die armut
stieg wieder schlagartig an und viele
regierungen bekam ernsthafte probleme
mit der rückzahlung ihrer schulden und
nicht nur das durch die korona krise
stiegen die ausgaben während die
einnahmen einbrachen wodurch sich der
finanzbedarf vieler staaten ist vielfach
die auswirkungen auf die
staatsverschuldung kannst du folgende
grafik entnehmen
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass die
ratingagenturen die kreditwürdigkeit
vieler länder herabgestuft haben sodass
heute 93 prozent afrikanischen
regierungen preis unterhalb des
investment grade ratings liegen das
heißt unterhalb der schwelle bei der
eine investition noch empfohlen wird
ihre staatsanleihen werden als junk als
ramschanleihen betrachtet die konsequenz
all diesen staaten stieg jetzt weniger
geld zur verfügung und das geld das sie
noch bekommen ist viel viel teurer
geworden
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier über einen
schuldenproblemen welche schließlich zu
einer finanz und wirtschaftskrise führen
könnte es ist wohlhabende länder wie
kenia äthiopien und kamerun dann nun in
die enge getrieben plötzlich stellen
hier alle alarmglocken erstens wegen der
gefahr neuer humanitärer krisen in
afrika welche in form von migranten
strömen sehr schnell auch nach europa
überschwappen könnten und zweitens wegen
des geopolitischen risikos welches
dieser flächenbrand mit sich bringt
wieso nun wenn wir über schulden und
afrika reden müssen wir auch über china
reden bereits dort ist schon prangerte
die perverse schuldenfallen diplomatie
des pseudo kommunistischen regimes in
peking an was aber ist seitdem geschehen
wie funktioniert jenas schulden masche
wie weit reichen seine absichten geht es
nur um die in afrika liegen den
wertvollen rohstoffe so die
schlüsseltechnologien des 21
jahrhunderts oder gar noch um viel viel
mehr in diesem video werden wir all
diese spannenden fragen klären also
aufgepasst
chinas kaufrausch in afrika
seit shipping an der macht ist afrika in
der chinesischen diplomatie mehr und
mehr an bedeutung gewonnen der
chinesische staatschef hat nicht nur
foren und begegnungsräume gefördert
sondern auch für reisen auf dem
kontinent unternommen man könnte also
sagen dass sie den pink präsenz in
afrika viel größer ist als die jedes
anderen großen internationalen führers
und das zeigt wirkung die chinesische
politik ist in die fußstapfen von chinas
wachsenden wirtschaftlichen beziehungen
zu afrika getreten oder war es eher die
wirtschaft die politik folgte was war
zuerst da eine oder wie auch immer seit
dem jahr 2000 westi us handel mit afrika
um mehr als 2.000 prozent gestiegen und
wird 2019 über 200 milliarden dollar
erreichen und das ist noch nicht alles
waren 2006 noch 800 leysin
staatsunternehmen auf dem afrikanischen
kontinent tätig sind es heute mehr als
10.000 öffentliche und private
unternehmen was china neben
großbritannien und frankreich zum
größten investor in der region macht
[Musik]
um die einen eindruck zu verschaffen 40
prozent des infrastrukturmarkt dass ein
erheblicher anteil der
bergbauaktivitäten und mehr als zwölf
prozent der gesamten industrieproduktion
in afrika sind bereits in den händen zu
jedes unternehmen
unternehmen wie trend der in shenzhen
ansässige handyhersteller den
afrikanischen markt anführt und fabriken
vor ort betreibt fabriken wie diejenige
die 2011 in addis abeba der hauptstadt
äthiopiens eröffnet wurde und in der
jetzt ja mehr als eine million
mobilfunkgeräte hergestellt werden
wir sprechen hier von einem engagement
das immer weiter wächst so hat der
chinesische botschafter in nigeria am 21
september 2021 verkündet dass eine der
größten chinesischen banken das
afrikanische land für ihren aggressiven
expansion feldzug ausgewählt hat china
hat nigeria aus einem bestimmten grund
gewählt es geht um erdöl die geraer ist
ein opec mitglied und verbucht seine
verkäufe in dollar mit diesem schritt
soll der nigerianische energiesektor
davon überzeugt werden zahlungen für
sein öl in yuan zu akzeptieren aber
warte eine sekunde denn wenn eines in
den letzten jahren aggressiv expandierte
dann waren es die schulden china ist
inzwischen der größte ausländische
kreditgeber in ganz afrika laut der
afrika china initiative der john hopkins
university beliefen sich die offiziellen
kredite der chinesischen regierung und
großer staatlicher unternehmen zwischen
2000 und 2008 auf mehr als 150
milliarden us dollar
in den letzten zwei jahrzehnten china
zum beispiel jedes fünfte
infrastrukturprojekt auf dem kontinent
finanziert werden viele dieser kredite
deren genaue bedingungen auf
ausdrücklichen wunsch pekings geheim
gehalten werden sind offenbar an
strategische starts güter als
sicherheiten gebunden oder sehen eine
begleichung der zinszahlungen und
rückzahlungen in rohstoffen vor dies
könnte zum beispiel ein guter der fall
sein dem land das mit abstand die
meisten tödliche von china erhalten hat
und ihren rückzahlung größtenteils mit
öl erfolgen würde die wir noch sehen
werden könnte dies eines der hauptziele
der asiatischen macht sein
was aber den gläubiger china angeht hört
ja mal an was begann das den
landesminister 2018 in einem brief an
präsident museveni schrieb in anbetracht
dessen was in vergleichbaren ländern in
bezug auf die verschuldung gegenüber
china passiert sind wir der festen
überzeugung dass wir unsere
wirtschaftsgüter vor einer möglichen
übernahme schützen sollten gut mit all
dem im hinterkopf gibt es ein paar
fragen die wir uns stellen müssen welche
langfristige agenda verfolgt china in
afrika ist die schuldenfalle ein teil
von ihr und wenn ja welche auswirkungen
hätte dieser ganze prozess auf den
afrikanischen kontinent genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal aus der nähe
an
[Musik]
die schuldenfalle
die große frage die wir uns alle stellen
müssen ist welche gegenleistungen
verlangt china wirklich für seine
finanzielle unterstützung und nein ich
meine damit nicht den zinssatz im jahr
2017 begannen donald trump auf die
problematik der chinesischen schulden
alle hinzuweisen nach jobs theorie würde
die chinesische regierung im grunde die
vergabe von öffentlichen krediten an
entwicklungsländer fördern mit dem
ekligen ziel sie bis zum hals in ihren
schulden versinken zu lassen um sie dann
zu kontrollieren und auszunutzen das
heißt und von ihnen zugeständnis zu
erhalten zu denen sie nicht bereit
gewesen wären bevor sie peking in eine
abhängigkeit und notlage gebracht hat um
zu sehen ob das alles sinn macht lasst
uns zuerst die frage nach dem motiv
beantworten welche vorteile könnte china
mit einem solchen vorgehen gewinnen okay
ich denke eines ist offensichtlich china
verschlingt rohstoffe wie verrückt und
wenn afrika etwas anzubieten hat dann
sind es eben natürliche ressourcen
mehr als ein drittel des erdöls china
importiert und 20 prozent baumwolle die
von chinesischen textilindustrie
verbraucht wird kommen aus afrika ganz
zu schweigen von rohstoffen wie mangan
dass wir die stahlproduktion unser
sichtbar ist oder coltan das für die
elektroindustrie und verzichtbar ist und
dessen größte vorkommen sich eben genau
auf diesen kontinent bis händen und das
sind jetzt nur ein paar beispiele von
ganz ganz viel
auf diese weise könnten die kredite eine
doppelte funktion haben einerseits den
aufbau einer infrastruktur die china
braucht um all diese ressourcen
ausbeuten zu können und andererseits die
regierungen in die schuldenfalle zu
locken damit peking die kontrolle über
eben diese ressourcen übernehmen kann
gut das motiv hätten wir also aber wie
sieht es mit weiteren indizien aus nun
wenn es eine sache gibt mir der peking
in letzter zeit aufgefallen ist dass
seine enormen politischen klimmzüge
[Musik]
was ich damit meine nur die ausnutzung
von schulden als verhandlungs
technischer himmel um direkten
politischen einfluss im tausch für
verbesserte kreditbedingungen oder
verlängerte rückzahlungsbedingungen zu
bekommen ihr möchtet konkrete beispiel
hören kein problem zum beispiel waren 25
der 53 länder die im jahr 2020 nach der
verabschiedung des nationalen
sicherheitsgesetze in hongkong einer
erklärung zu unterstützen und chinas im
un-menschenrechtsrat unterzeichneten
afrikanische länder und drei weitere
große länder nigeria südafrika und kenia
unterstützt das gesetz zwar nicht
schlossen sich aber auch nicht der
kritik an peking an und genau das
gleiche geschah mit den anklagen gegen
die verfolgung der uiguren und anderer
ethnischer minderheiten viele
afrikanische länder haben china in
internationalen organisationen
unterstützt ebenso unterstützen die
stimmen afrikanische länder die wahl
chinesischer vertreter an die spitze
wichtige internationale institutionen
wie falle der ernährungs und
landwirtschaftsorganisation der
vereinten nationen die ab 2019 von einem
vertreter der chinesischen regierung
geleitet wird was zu einem großen teil
eben auf afrikanischen stimmen
zurückzuführen ist
okay es ist also klar wasser abläuft die
schulden liegen afrikanischen
regierungen gewährt werden haben peking
ein enormes verhandlungsgeschick
gebracht habe ist dass die ganze
geschichte afrika braucht kapital es
braucht ins struktur es braucht
investitionen und hier könnte china eine
wichtige rolle spielen wenn die frage
die wir uns hier zu stellen könnten
lautet haben sich die dinge in afrika in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten verbessert
oder nicht
ich glaube nicht dass es einen
absichtlichen plan chinas gibt irgendein
lang zu verschulden ich glaube dass
china eine sehr wichtige rolle spielt
nämlich die der infrastrukturförderung
sagt akin omi alles die nahe präsident
der afrikanischen entwicklungsbank und
vielleicht liegt ist sogar in pekings
ureigensten interesse dass afrika
kräftig wächst denn betrachtet man das
derzeitige wirtschafts und
entwicklungsmodell chinas so muss das
land in den nächsten zwei jahrzehnten
mit einer enorm alternden bevölkerung zu
recht kommen wir sprechen hier über eine
demografische lage die der bereits voll
entwickelter industrieländer entspricht
die damit verbundene enorme belastungen
der renten- und gesundheitssysteme sind
jedoch nur zu stemmen wenn ein land
einen hohen wertschöpfungs grad aufweist
daher muss chinas wirtschaftsmodell noch
schneller weg von billigprodukten die
viele ressourcen verschlingen hin zu
einem großen anteil an hochwertigen
gütern des mittleren bis oberen
marktsegments mit ausreichender
wertschöpfung bei diesen produkten stößt
ist jedoch bereits auf die starke
konkurrenz europäischer japanischer
koreanischer und vor allem us firmen
darüber hinaus rechnet china mit
weiteren politischen konflikten mit den
usa und kann sich daher nicht
ausschließlich auf die usa als
hauptabnehmer seine exporte verlassen
deshalb haben ländern geld um ihre
infrastruktur aufzubauen und ihren
bürgern zu mehr wohlstand und kaufkraft
zu verhelfen
im gegenzug sollen diese chinesische
waren kaufen und dafür hat bieten
bereits einen fuß in die türen dieser
märkte gesetzt und egal wie viel wir
über die schuldenfalle reden und wie
viel uns von washington erzählt wird wir
können eine realität nicht ignorieren
die volksrepublik china als vasen
größten kreditgeber afrikas geworden
aber bei weitem nicht dem einzigen
china kontrolliert etwa 25 prozent der
afrikanischen auslandsschulden das ist
zwar viel aber es bedeutet auch dass die
restlichen 45 prozent in den händen
anderer länder oder organisationen
liegen allein der anteil der weltbank
und des iwf an afrikas schulden ist fast
ebenso groß wie der china und in diesen
beiden institutionen haben vor allem
westliche staaten das sagen bei näherer
betrachtung finden wir nur drei staaten
sambia dschibuti und die demokratische
republik kongo die sich zum großteil bei
jena verschuldet haben aber fassen wir
noch einmal zusammen china zieht
politischen nutzen aus einem wachsenden
beziehungen china aber offenbar nutzen
afrika die chinesischen investitionen ja
auch ja nicht alles ist so einfach wie
es scheint die welt besteht nicht nur
aus schwarz und weiß aber aufgepasst
denn es gibt noch einen weiteren
wichtigen faktor den wir beachten müssen
china finanziert was immer es will was
er vollkommen in ordnung ist aber dies
ist eben auch der springende punkt über
den wir uns vollkommen im klaren sein
müssen china finanziert was immer es
will
[Musik]
und genau darin liegt das problem denn
was wäre wenn die geförderten projekte
wirtschaftlich überhaupt nicht sinnvoll
sind das ist ja schließlich etwas was in
china selbst passiert eine studie der
oxford university aus dem jahr 2016 hat
zum beispiel gezeigt dass mehr als die
hälfte aller infrastrukturprojekte in
china in den letzten 30 jahren nicht die
gewünschte leistung erbracht haben laut
dieser studie kommt nur 28 prozent der
projekte als wirtschaftlich wirksam
eingestuft werden oder anders gefragt
was ist wenn das chinesische modell
nicht funktioniert insbesondere afrika
der chinesischen regierung stehen ja
genügend ressourcen zur verfügung um sie
für überdimensionierte unnötige und
redundante infrastruktur zu verschwenden
einfach mal ins blaue hinein investieren
die chinesen können es sich leisten aber
genau das ist bei afrikanischen
regierungen eher nicht der fall
vielleicht handelt es sich hierbei um
eine unbeabsichtigte nebenwirkungen von
chinas krediten und investitionen bei
diesem thema ist also große vorsicht
geboten
denn wenn projekte eine schlechte
wirtschaftliche rendite haben bedeutet
dies dass die möglicherweise nicht genug
erwirtschaften um die schulden
zurückzuzahlen
natürlich muss das nicht so sein afrika
braucht investitionen und niemand konnte
die auswirkung der korona kläser
vorhersehen es ist klar dass
ausländische direktinvestitionen besser
sind als blinde finanzhilfen die dann
irgendwo in den taschen korrupter
politiker und für waffenkäufe versickern
um die lokale bevölkerung noch besser
unterdrücken zu können aber es ist auch
klar dass peking jedes mittel nutzen
wird um sich einen politischen vorteil
zu verschaffen selbst wenn das bedeutet
dass es mit gruppenführern geschäfte
macht und kredite für fragwürdige zwecke
vergibt aber wenn es jemanden gibt der
letztendlich verantwortlich ist das ist
die afrikanischen führer selbst auf
jeden fall sollten wir eher optimistisch
sein das aufgebaute capital setzt sich
durch china ist sehr afrikas motion
interessiert und alles deute darauf hin
dass wir in einem zyklus steigender
rohstoffpreise eintreten
[Musik]
ein zyklus der dem afrikanischen
kontinent die finanzmittel verschaffen
könnte die er braucht um die krise zu
überwinden und auf den wachstumspfad
zurückzukehren den er in den letzten 20
jahren schon einmal einschlagen konnte
was ist also unser fazit ja die
chinesische schulden diplomatie gibt es
aber man sollte sie auch nicht
überbewerten wollen sie ist nicht das
einzige problem wie so oft ist eine
monokausale betrachtung ist angebracht
sondern eine differenzierte wenn die
chinesische präsenz in afrika ein grund
zur sorge ist müssen die westlichen
regierungen nach wegen suchen um die
investitionen auf diesem kontinent und
die integration der afrikanischen länder
in die weltwirtschaft zu verbessern so
und jetzt bist du dran glaubst du dass
china die schulden wirklich nur als
politische waffe einsetzt was sollten
die westlichen mächte deiner meinung
nach tun sollten sie sich wehren sollten
sich hinauswachsen einfluss in afrika
kontern und wenn ja mit welchen mitteln
wie immer sind wir auf eure meinung zu
diesem thema schon gespannt ich hoffe
also dass euch dieses video gefallen hat
war es ja gibt es mit teil des mit
freunden und vergesst nicht das abo mit
glöckchen um keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]